the Trump administration's plan to roll
back mandatory insurance coverage for
birth control faces a new federal court
challenge Washington State's Attorney
General sued yesterday to stop the new
rules from taking effect California and
Massachusetts have already filed similar
complaints last week the administration
said it is changing the Obamacare
requirement that health plans cover
contraception it wants to exempt any
non-government employer with a quote
religious or moral objection Adriana
Diaz is on the campus of Notre Dame
University in Indiana which welcomes the
changes
Adriana good morning good morning
because of the Catholic Church has
strict stance against contraception
Notre Dame has fought the birth control
mandate for years and though it hasn't
decided to completely withdraw coverage
yet some women on this campus are
worried about losing a part of their
health care coverage I respect my
University's adherence to Catholicism
but I also think that no woman should
have to choose between her serious
medical needs and her University's
religion Notre Dame law student Kate
Roche signed up for the university
health plan just last year and it could
already be in for a drastic change the
school may drop birth control coverage
following the trumpet administration's
announcement Friday at this point in my
life I don't have a disposable income to
go out and seek out contraceptives or
like a private insurance provider the
new rules would give quote conscience
protections to employers based on their
religious or moral convictions this
includes nonprofits and publicly traded
companies under the Obama administration
only houses of worship could be exempt
come on up here sister come on up
president Trump signaled to the
regulatory changes in May when he
invited these nuns who had challenged
the birth control mandate in court to
the Rose Garden with this executive
order we are ending the attacks on your
religious liberty Houston Baptist
University President Robert Sloan says
the old rules forced his institution to
cover emergency contraception like plan
B which he considers a form of abortion
as the new rules protect freedom of
religion because the government does not
have the right to tell the Little
Sisters of the Poor
or Notre Dame or any Catholic
institution what its own religious
convictions are 58 percent of women use
oral contraceptive pills for reasons
beyond birth control like treating the
disease endometriosis or menstrual pain
those pills can cost more than a
thousand dollars a year without
insurance Roche a member of the ACLU is
now a plaintiff in the group's lawsuit
challenging the Trump administration
rules was it difficult for you to decide
to speak out coming forward about such a
personal matter is a really scary
prospect
but at the end of the day a lot of women
on campus feel that this is an unfair
intrusion into our private rights the
new regulations are expected to be
published on Friday the Trump
administration estimates that 200
employers could take advantage of the
exemption potentially impacting 120,000
women Norah
all right Adriana thank you